in our morning rounds a groundbreaking
way to spot eye disease detecting vision
problems in young children can be a
challenge because they normally don't
know what normal vision even looks like
now an app that scans photos on your
smartphone can instantly identify
unusual glares that could be a sign of
27 different eye conditions Omar
Villafranca shows us how one little
boy's painful struggle inspired his
father to help other families before
their children lose their sight landon
lessman acts like any other curious and
playful six-year-old
but what you can't see is that Landon
has coates disease a blood-vessel
disorder that left him with limited
vision in one of his eyes his mom Sarah
says the clues were hard to spot Landon
was a little delayed in all of his gross
motor and fine motor development he had
a really hard time going down and up
stairs 4 years ago Lessman noticed a
white glare in her son's left eye in
pictures taken with the flash the Texas
mom thought it was just bad lighting
until she started doing some research
I'd remember seeing some kind of news
article or news report about a little
boy having cancer in his eye and it was
caught by a glow in the eye like that
and my mom alarm bells started going off
Lessman downloaded cradle' an app that
Stan's photos already on your phone for
white eye glares which can be a symptom
of Coates disease cataracts or even a
type of eye cancer called retinoblastoma
the app found several white glares and a
specialist confirmed Landon had coates
disease Lessman credits a app with
preventing even worse damage to Landon's
vision had I not seen that I would have
probably let it go for I don't know how
long dr. Davinder Grover is Landon
specialists and says warning signs in
children can be easily missed because
they're amazing they can function
extremely well with a tremendous vision
loss so they can easily trick people
doctors they can't usually trick mom
though so usually it's mom that kind of
figures it out the algorithm saw a pupil
that was wider than it should have
Brian Shaw created cradle to help spot
symptoms not easily seen by the naked
eye people started using it immediately
in the first few months it was
downloaded I think about 80,000 times
these that one should the Baylor
University biochemist knows all too well
the importance of catching eye disease
early his oldest son Noah was diagnosed
with retinal blastoma at four months old
Shaw says he remembers seeing unusual
glares in pictures of Noah just days
after his birth but didn't realize that
unlike the red eye typically seen in
flash photos a white glow could be a
sign of trouble by the time Noah's eye
cancer was diagnosed it was too late to
save his right eye if we got a minute 12
days old he wouldn't have lost his eye
and he wouldn't have received 30 cycles
of proton beam radiation to his
remaining eye that we were able to
salvage what is that moment like when
something that you've created is keeping
someone else from going through the pain
that your son had to go through that's
the best feeling in the world there's no
better reward there's nothing like
seeing your technology your idea help
out another person in particular a kid
dr. David Abramson with Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center says that
while I apps can generate false
positives any white glares should be
checked out quickly to limit disruption
to early vision development with a child
who has a cataract for weeks months or
years even removing that cataract will
never restore vision because it was
never imprinted into the brain Bryan
Shaw urges parents to keep taking
pictures of their kids and look a little
closer at their eyes take a lot of
pictures and if you see white pupils and
your children don't panic don't be
alarmed but tell your doctor Omar
Villafranca CBS News Waco Texas